- [Instructor] We're asked
to find the value of x
in the isosceles triangle shown below.
So that is the base of this triangle.
So pause this video and see
if you can figure that out.
Well the key realization to solve this
is to realize that this
altitude that they dropped,
this is going to form a right angle here
and a right angle here
and notice,
both of these triangles,
because this whole thing
is an isosceles triangle,
we're going to have two
angles that are the same.
This angle, is the same as that angle.
Because it's an isosceles triangle,
this 90 degrees is the
same as that 90 degrees.
And so the third angle
needs to be the same.
So that is going to be the same as that
right over there.
And since you have two
angles that are the same
and you have a side between them
that is the same
this altitude of 12 is on both triangles,
we know that both of these
triangles are congruent.
So they're both going to have 13
they're going to have one side that's 13,
one side that is 12
and so this
and this side are going to be the same.
So this is going to be x over two
and this is going to be x over two.
And so now we can use that information
and the fact and the Pythagorean Theorem
to solve for x.
Let's use the Pythagorean Theorem
on this right triangle
on the right hand side.
We can say that
x over two squared
that's the base right over here
this side right over here.
We can write that x over two
squared
plus the other side
plus 12 squared
is going to be equal to
our hypotenuse squared.
Is going to be equal to 13 squared.
This is just the Pythagorean Theorem now.
And so we can simplify.
This is going to be x.
We'll give that the same color.
This is going to be x squared over four.
That's just x squared over two squared
plus 144
144 is equal to 13 squared is 169.
Now I can subtract 144 from both sides.
I'm gonna try to solve for x.
That's the whole goal here.
So subtracting 144 from both sides
and what do we get?
On the left hand side, we have x squared
over four is equal to 169 minus 144.
Let's see, 69 minus 44 is 25.
So this is going to be equal to 25.
We can multiply both sides by four
to isolate the x squared.
And so we get x squared
is equal to 25 times four
is equal to 100.
Now, if you're just looking
this purely mathematically
and say, x could be
positive or negative 10.
But since we're dealing with distances,
we know that we want the
positive value of it.
So x is equal to the principle root of 100
which is equal to positive 10.
So there you have it.
We have solved for x.
This distance right here, the whole thing,
the whole thing is
going to be equal to 10.
Half of that is going to be five.
So if we just looked at
this length over here.
I'm doing that in the
same column, let me see.
So this length right over here,
that's going to be five
and indeed, five squared plus 12 squared,
that's 25 plus 144
is 169, 13 squared.
So the key of realization here is
isosceles triangle,
the altitudes splits it into
two congruent right triangles
and so it also splits this base into two.
So this is x over two
and this is x over two.
And we use that information
and the Pythagorean Theorem
to solve for x.